[Musique]
charles joseph de haguenau qu'était donc
le propriétaire du château
avait proposé de faire contre de
construire cette maison pour accueillir
des soeurs de charité historiquement
c'était important pour celui qui l'a
fabriqué de promettre d'avoir des
religieuses de pour les accueillir et à
châteaufort et pour la commune nous
estimons que c'est la première façade du
demandeur ce qu'on voit en arrivant de
l'extérieur de châteaufort
[Musique]
nous souhaitons faire de cette maison
une maison d'accueil et d'exposition
pour montrer ce qu'est le domaine dorce
ce qui est une réserve naturelle
régionale en général et la particularité
de la nôtre l'idée à l'intérieur est
d'avoir au rez de chaussée une
exposition permanente pour expliquer ce
qu'est le domaine d'or c'est la réserve
naturelle cette exposition serait
permanente est ouverte à tous en
permanence et à l'arrière il y aurait
une salle qui permettrait d'organiser
lorsqu'il ya des visites un bar des
boissons fin de quelque chose de plus
convivial
[Musique]